hey do you guys want to see flat-out
insanity do you want to see what happens
when religious right-winger ISM infects
your brain in a way that no medication
can cure asked what she thought of the
2005 [ __ ] gate comments Donald Trump
supporter vicki CEO Lee ro told CNN's
Brooke Baldwin that she is not worried
because number one Trump is not running
for Pope and if he knew that he was
being recorded he wouldn't have said
those things I would definitely not let
children under 10 years of age see this
let him see a rated R movie or something
that the religious right things would
destroy their lives forever
it would be way less damaging than
watching this let's take a look together
as adults now how do you feel hearing
that well obviously it was very
offensive however I think it's totally
irrelevant I mean it was so long ago
and I do believe that most men will talk
about women in ways that they would
never talk about publicly enough and of
course if they would have known that
they were being recorded ID there's no
doubt in my mind they would the
conversation would been totally
different nobody is perfect here's the
issues last night in that debate they
defined their issues they line the marks
in the sand
number one roe v-- wade okay Hillary
Clinton doesn't care about murdering
babies dismembering abortions that's
okay with her okay it's a religious
freedom
oh yes yes you talked on substance and
that is important Vikki but we're
talking about locker room coming yes my
question was about is it okay that a man
who wants to be the president of the
free world is bragging and admits to it
yes he's apologized yeah well is that
that's wrong okay yes but that is that
that is that is wrong absolutely but
here's the thing he's not running to be
the Pope look at the culture of our
country everybody knew he had strip
clubs but still the millions of people
chose him to be the nominee I mean this
is that this is the kind of person that
needs to lead our country God can use
anybody he used he used the harlots and
that's what it's all about
what God can do God can't do this God
can use this man but you know the things
that was all apart from this adult man
who is running to be President of the
United States
millions of children hurt that boys and
girls and boys may take their cues from
this guy who wants to be our president
and behave in a court of the thing when
Bill Clinton was president when Bill
Clinton was president my children came
home from school and they had no idea
was actually called the Oval Office they
thought it was called the oral Office
because of yeah the talk in the
elementary schools okay
educated my children at a much younger
age than I wanted to but Vicky Bill
Clinton isn't running for president
right now about Hillary Clinton no but
his wife is his wife is and they are a
pair the two are one so every statement
made by this insane woman totally
fallacious right Trump knew if he knew
he was being recorded he would have
spoken differently so the recordings not
valuable yet with Hillary Clinton when
we get leaked audio and speech
transcripts they're relevant because she
didn't know she was being recorded at
complete conflict Hillary Clinton
doesn't care about dismembering abortion
I mean that's ridiculous the the the
Pope doesn't run to be Pope so what does
that even mean that Trump isn't running
for Pope my particular kids happen to be
younger when Clinton had the Monica
Lewinsky scandal so that makes it worse
than what Trump did because my kids are
older now that they're hearing the Trump
tapes
this is off-the-wall insanity I don't
know how you even think that you you're
gonna represent a campaign if you're
this woman Plus Trump now should know
too that he's going to be recorded I
mean he's on a bus for Access Hollywood
you should be making remarks like
understanding that you have a mic on and
this could come back to bite you uh yeah
I I think you can never talk sense into
someone like this right Rachel I mean if
we had four hours with this woman ten
hours in a room this is what she
believed and that's that yeah we should
totally get her on the show a very
nonsensical argument
another thing that I don't understand is
kind of again her hypocrisy with the
religion aspect of it saying again run
for Pope that doesn't make sense but
then also saying that God can use him so
I don't really understand apoco that
doesn't make sense
but then God can use them so where where
is the straight line of religion here
it's not adding up not to mention if God
can use anyone how does she know God
isn't planning to use Hillary Clinton I
mean that that's just as legitimate of a
question insane this is what we're
dealing with she also did say that truck
originally she did say that Trump was
her next-to-last
choice also which is interesting yeah I
wonder I'd love to get this woman's
ranking of people candidates me too
disturbing for sure Brooke Baldwin
they're able to do nothing but put her
head her head in her hands let's take a
break we will take a break and be back
with much more after this